[Музика]
Член Зари не абрикосовий,
він є поточним власником
бази даних грибів Keepo doom, який
м'яз, якщо віджет Бойда a в пара-
західному розбрат о солодке o Аллах
дуже професійний трохи звичайний
kshitij - Сатана Будда  поділіться але
мусульманський стюард гуру блондинка не так
це дуже Емма ніч він грає мені
етикет або буддизм все зрозумів
вибачте Banco
[музика]
так що привіт хлопці пора
уроку англійської мене звати Наталія лешка давайте
почнемо
і я хотів би привітати  мої дорогі
гості сьогодні
Наталія привіт, як ви, привіт, хлопці а
я Наталія МакГі Ліпскомб сьогодні я
дуже добре сьогодні добре
ідеально що з тобою Слава привіт як справи
, я був радий бачити вас
бачити Наталю з -  Наталія Я можу побажати
Єлані, але я
бажаю загадати бажання загадай бажання 12 балів
відразу ж перейти до вас дякую, тому
сьогодні ми поговоримо про фільми
різні типи фільмів давайте почнемо
добре, але перед цим нам потрібно, щоб наші
студенти попередньо  домашнє завдання, і для цього
я створив для вас гру, добре,
так що подивіться на картинку, це
дуже маленька частина зображення, добре, спробуйте
вгадати, що це, що це, що це таке, що є
м'яч так і жінка, яка жінка, ви
бачите жіночу частину  з боку ви бачите
багато м'ячів, якщо ми думаємо про діяльність,
то що ви можете робити після занять, що
це може бути, що ви можете робити після
занять, що ми можемо зробити після обробки старого
баскетболу, тому ми називаємо це теніс
так, займайтеся спортом, ви займаєтесь  спорт, щоб ми могли
займатися спортом добре
наступне фото Я думаю, що це Наталя
вгадає так, я думаю, що це 40p Анна
так,
це фортепіано, і якщо ми думаємо
про діяльність, то що ми робимо, ми займаємося
спортом, а з піаніно що ми робимо
чи ти музику так, ми можемо грати ми прибираємо,
ми можемо посидіти так, ми можемо
грати музику або ми граємо на фортепіано, добре, це
пише в Корані,
добре, ні музики, добре, ми можемо відтворити новини,
наші слова працюють з попереднього
уроку грати  фортепіано добре добре це
дуже важливо робити sp  orts no article base
article О грай на фортепіано,
нам потрібно сказати, що фортепіано добре добре
грай на фортепіано ні, це неправильно грай на цьому
фортепіано мм-хм добре, що це таке, це
дуже складне питання це, можливо,
шоколад, я допоможу тобі
ах це  фільм, будь ласка, автомобіль так, якщо ви
думаєте про активність
зі спортом, ми грали на фортепіано, що це
може зробити фільм, ви можете зробити фільм,
але студенти, вони насправді не знімають
фільми, вони що вони роблять, щоб дивитися
так, вони дивляться фільм  або
дивитися фільм, не має значення, ви можете сказати
дивитися фільм дивитися фільми добре, тож
давайте поговоримо про різні типи
фільмів і давайте вивчати нові слова готовий
добре добре, у нас сьогодні багато типів фільмів,
тепер давайте один за одним добре  скажімо,
фільм з великою кількістю дійства, багато
речей відбувається, він дуже активний, тому ми
називаємо це пригодницьким так пригодницьким, чи можете ви
повторювати за мною пригодницькими пригодами
так, Андрій, будь ласка, пригодницькими
пригодницькими фантастичними новими фільмами, які знімають
уявне майбутнє  re ні уявне майбутнє
фантастичне так
офіційно ми називаємо це наукова фантастика
наукова фантастика
Браво Слава наукова фантастика і твоя
черга добре скажи, давайте перейдемо до наступного
і відчуймо, що серія малюнків складається з
мультфільму так або ми називаємо це анімаційним
мультфільмом ха-ха це було б  бути дуже
коротким курсором мультфільму, це змусило його
рухатися так, які анімаційні фільми можливі
так можливо, також аніме відбувалося в
основному ми просто говоримо мультфільми більшістю
розмовної мови, що скорочено до
мультфільму, але якщо ми думаємо офіційно, якщо
ви створюєте кіно професіонали
сказав би
анімаційний мультфільм добре добре давайте підемо
фільм, який змушує вас сміятися комедія так
комедія це не комедія комедія що якщо
уявіть, що це людина, яка говорить
перед і змушує вас сміятися, але
це вистава, це не фільм, добре,
фільм  про американських ковбоїв, що це за
вестерн-вестерн, так і імма, дозволь тобі
забути, що це так просто
такі проблеми, як
лірика «Титанік» так,
драматичні фільми, мабуть, тому що ми
жінки, і ми любимо драми.
Вау, так, ми любимо драми наступний
, я відчуваю, що перебував у минулому, тому
історія так, назва теми —
історія, але назва  фільм
історичний так Джордан Крик Матунук
історичний так так назва фільму
історичний фільм мм-хм чи можете ви повторити
ще раз історичний фільм історичний фільм
дякую так страшний фільм що це за
страшний фільм страшний
страшний ну це фільм жахів або
жахів  фільм і ми зазвичай не говоримо,
коли слово закінчується на неї, ми не
вимовляємо це жах фільм жахів фільм
жахів фільм жахів і останній на сьогодні
фільм про злочин і детектив, який
його розслідує, кажуть, що це за
детектив так,
дякую  Наталія ідеальна студентка
детектив детектив гарний тепер
давайте переглянемо всі фільми, щоб
пам'ятати картинка що це за весталка добра
яка ця драма і ця пригода
добре цей історичний добре давайте
продовжуємо  e за одним так знову ця одна пригодницька
наукова фантастика номер три
мультфільм анімація цей о, я зробив
комедію давайте повторимо ще раз комедія комедія
італійська комедія так, дякую, і цей
, звичайно, так і наступна
драма і наступна драма
жахів так  і останній він
активний, це легко, добре,
тепер подивіться, нам потрібно запам'ятати слова,
і для цього нам потрібно вимовляти його
багато разів, наприклад повторити
детектив детектив детектив це
нудно, ми можемо зробити його цікавішим,
тому ми повторюємо одне за одним  просто назвіть це,
але в якийсь момент фотографії
зникнуть. Карта періоду Торіяма, яку
ми могли бачити, коли ми знімали, Аллах поставив акіту,
коли сучасний мультфільм показував рекламу Наката,
тому нам потрібно це пам'ятати, добре, давайте спробуємо,
щоб ви хотіли піти зі мною О,
без  з тобою зі мною
поїхали Пригоди пригоди
науково-фантастичний мультфільм комедія
західна драма детектив так наприклад
люблю зникати пригоди
мультфільм комедія Браво
добре т  ще зникнути пригодницька комедія
комедія вестерн історичний детектив
Браво ви прив’яжіть ще два зникнення
пригодницька науково-фантастична комедія де
західна драма драма на чверть або
і детектив давайте всі картинки
зникнуть і давайте учні
з екрану повторять добре скажи пригода
що було далі
AB  розділ так так пригоди наукова
фантастика анімаційний мультфільм комедія
вестерн драма історичний жах
я детектив
Браво давайте продовжимо чи можете ви вгадати це
слово
що це за драма так
правильно один бал для вас Слава
молодець Наталя давайте зробимо
так вам потрібно переглянути  тобі треба
швидше відповісти що це
Наталя абсолютно права так що це
один добре ой я бачу комедію наступний один жах
так що бігти добре
давайте якнайшвидше
ладно наступний це цікаво
детектив Браун о так це для - давайте
перевіримо -  - Отже, Пітер МакЕндрюс, а
англійською ми говоримо: «Нічия», «
Нічию», «Гей, намалював», давайте йти далі, тому я
збираюся прочитати текст для вас.  ви не
бачите тексту, але у мене є запитання до вас,
поки я читаю текст, спробуйте відповісти,
що подобається Пітеру, а що подобається Лаурі,
які фільми добре, тому послухайте
діалог, я його прочитаю, а потім  Я
задам тобі питання вже добре
привіт, піца, у тебе є якісь плани на
вихідні, не зовсім чому я йду в
кіно, щоб подивитися на вулиці до церкви по
суботах, я завжди насолоджуюсь посміятися,
ти хочеш прийти?  Мені дуже подобаються
комедії, вони повинні бути смішними,
але я зазвичай вважаю їх нудними, я віддаю перевагу
драми, чому б нам не піти на «Титанік»,
це на цьому тижні на «Астерії», ви знаєте
постійні драми, вони занадто депресивні,
я б краще дивився  гарний історичний
фільм на кшталт «Лінкольна», який набагато
цікавіший, це одна загадка - на
екрані - мені дуже подобаються історичні фільми,
і я думаю, що Деніел Дей-Льюїс дивовижний,
принаймні, ми домовилися про щось,
давайте підемо на 9:00 показ у
суботу чудово  До зустрічі, Ден, я
покажу тобі текст, щоб все було  мені буде
легше для вас добре,
і маю запитання Пітер любить, що таке
драма, добре й історичне, давайте перевіримо
драму та історію чому у нас є
драма відповідь чи можете ви знайти її в текстовому
доказі, він сказав, що я не дуже люблю
командні комедійні комедії  комедії так, я
віддаю перевагу драми так, а як щодо
другої історичної, тому що про
Лінкольна і вона сказала про Лінкольна,
і він сказав, що йому подобається історичне
відчуття, так, я дуже любив історичні фільми,
і я думаю, що Деніел Дей-Льюїс
дивовижний, добре, Наталя питання  тобі
про Лауру,
так що Лора більше любить добре
кохання, добре,
а так добре сміється, це не який
фільм і історичний так, так їй подобається фільм
про Лінкольна, і тому вони
підуть я думаю, щоб зробити кіно для історичного
так  ви абсолютно праві, тож
Лора любить комедії та історичні
фільми, правильно, чому ми коментуємо, як
ви згадували, просто щоб довести
студентам, що вона сказала, що я завжди люблю
гарне кохання, і він сказав, що так
це комедія, ми це доводимо, і історичні
фільми про посилання. О, ви пам'ятаєте це
добре, тепер настав час вікторини, тому вікторина,
це насправді перевірка невеликого тесту,
чи вам подобаються тести, я кажу, що перший,
тому це гра у вгадування, я збираюся  щоб
написати слово тут, але все найлегше
я буду заплутатися спробуйте
вгадати слово добре добре, тому якщо я почну писати
дуже швидко західний так точно так, ви
спробуйте вгадати мене дуже швидко
Савва отримав один бал знову готова
драма так  це дуже швидко, тому два
бали на я добре, так що це для вас
особливо готові
давайте йти на так привезли ви були швидше
і ще один
ні вона не швидше
так я не вгадав перший західний так
так добре, давайте раніше за мене
Наталія  це критично так Браво дуже дякую,
зараз запитання до вас, подивіться на
малюнок і слова, чи збігаються вони так
правильно так добре
що щодо цього ні ні це неправильно, а
що щодо цього
це сцени
наукова фантастика
фантастика так  але  ти насправді
вимовляв це правильно, але різні
слова, оскільки функція функціонує, але вони сказали, що це
добре слова тепер також існують між словами,
тому що ви можете знайти будь-які слова
так, які західні добре, що ще
драма добре, а Наталія і Слав
шукають слова знайти слова  слова
самі швидко ви бачите їх на
екрані є сім слів добре так або
вестерн жах і що таке мм-хм,
тож давайте разом перевіримо готові давайте підемо
фільм чи подивіться фільм, що це за
мультфільм, драма, комедія, комедія із західним
портом, хорою та пригодами  у вас те
саме з вашим другом, добре, тепер трохи
драматизму, і моє типове запитання до всіх моїх
гостей,
чи подобається вам бабуся чи ні, ні, ні, ні,
нам потрібно вивчити бабусю добре, трохи
грубіше, я зроблю це легким для вас,
добре
погодився, тож давайте подивимося на мою піраміду фільмів,
так що музика трьох сердець подобається
- твердість Мені начебто подобається одна охота,
я можу це дивитися, але не можу сказати, що
мені це дуже подобається, тому мої
улюблені прийшли  es
я люблю дивитися комедії мм-хм я також
люблю дивитися мультфільми
ти любиш дивитися мультфільми
ні ні мені подобається, який твій улюблений матч
я дозволю мені піти з відео, це також
добре, і білка там божевільна так
Керол Лі фотометрія впевнена  Я кажу,
що Маршал не був я
багато з фільму
прямо наступний - це пригодницькі фільми,
тактичні фільми, поділіться своїми улюбленими так,
це моя піраміда, західна наукова
фантастика, і я дуже не люблю фільми жахів,
я їх не люблю, я їх не дивлюся
, тому подумай про себе  піраміди фільму
Наталія, куди б ти поставила своїх
кінозірок, щоб їхні три серця
були найулюбленішими, ти їх любиш, а
потім підіймешся до тих, які
ти справді не займаєш,
я думаю, історична комедія на другому місці,
а анімаційна анімація  Тед мультфільми добре
драма хороша наука детектив називає
наукову фантастику вестерни і
фільми жахів ти не любиш фільми жахів
цей відомий я ніколи не бачу я навіть ніколи не
бачу о, бачу, я їх теж не дивлюся,
так мені здається  Наталія, вони
не люблять фільми жахів, я люблю я
люблю хороші речі, і все ж таки Вашта жовто-
блакитна так
Ванна Ваня Кайова розмовляла з Форрестом
Гампом, чи це може бути камінь, хм, це може бути,
що насправді матеріальна людина, це також може
бути драма так, це  також про
соціальні проблеми, тому це може бути вирішення
соціальних як це мотиваційні
мотиваційні способи хіпі і був щасливий
і мої улюблені коміки, яких ви знаєте,
історичні можуть бути детективом
добре драма хороші анімаційні мультфільми так
жахи знає
так фільми жахів і науково-фантастичний
фільм фантастичний фільм  і вестерни хороші,
тож вестерни вони вам не подобаються
так, я не намагаюся добре, тому з точки зору
граматики щось, що нам дійсно подобається, ми
говоримо, що я люблю, і використовуємо форму ing я люблю
дивитися О так, я lo  я дивлюся комедії,
ти можеш повторити, поговори зі мною
я люблю комедії Браво
те, що я пишу, я люблю або мені подобається я люблю
тут люблю люблю люблю все гаразд не люблю
люблю люблю так добре, я люблю дивитися, це
також правильно так, звичайно, але вам мені
це подобається  про людей знають, що любов
– це дуже сильне почуття, тому ви також можете
любити, я люблю це,
ви маєте на увазі, що ви вчитеся справді любите
це робити ви хочете підкреслити це,
що Chrysler може зробити,
просто скажіть трохи їх, щоб ви могли
скажи мені це дуже подобається або я люблю це те
саме це те саме о так це легко так
як це добре любов сильніша дійсно
люблю слова так,
але головне, що ми використовуємо
форму я люблю дивитися драми я люблю
дивитися мультфільми добре або я  не люблю
дивитися, але
я не люблю, ти можеш сказати, що у мене все добре, я
не можу знайти їхню ситуацію
сильний не такий сильний,
ти або любиш це, як це, або тобі це не
подобається  Це три варіанти, тож давайте
зосередимося на цих двох. Мені подобається дивитися Мені
не подобається дивитися всі інші слова, як-от
грати, плавати, читати, готувати та прибирати, щоб ви могли
сказати, що мені подобається читати, що про вас,
Наталія, я люблю читати, я люблю плавати, я
люблю навіть пірнати  добре, я люблю готувати, я
роблю це дуже добре і дуже смачно, і я
люблю грати, і я не люблю чистоту.
але ні, ні
набори для прибирання дуже гарні після
приготування твої друзі, ти хочеш їсти
добре, а
ти розкажи нам, що тобі подобається, я
люблю готувати, плавати, читати так просто,
і я не люблю чисте прибирання, прибирання,
ти також не люблю я  не люблю
прибирати після Наталії смачно вона
не схвалює
ні так, ну нове
давайте зіграємо ще одну гру, у
нас будуть ігри всі r  добре, так скажи мені,
просто дайте
мені назви фільмів, я
їх запишу, так що ви пам'ятаєте божевільна
комедія добре
наукова фантастика гарна наукова фантастика
фантастика жахів або жахи західна
драма, добре, ми зупинимося тут, вони пам'ятають
усі слова  отже, це буде
гра з спінером, тому я обертаю світ, у
нас є назва фільму історичний
фільм, і вони мають до вас запитання, чи
любите ви дивитися історичні фільми,
чи не любите дивитися, тому скажіть мені, що я
не люблю дивитися або мені подобається дивитися
і готовий тип фільму, так що готова справжня
гра добре Наталія, ти будеш
першою драмою Мені подобається JAMA дуже
дякую і подія була щасливою, і ти можеш сказати
ще раз
мені подобається дивитися драму з  позитивна
прихильність з більш важким Браво
Слава Мені не подобається вестерн, тому що я
не знаю, що ти робиш із вестерном, ти
дивишся II не люблю дивитися вестерн,
добре Italia О, знову драма, я люблю драму,
завжди шепоче добре, що сумний кінець
наукова фантастика наукова фантастика  Я не
люблю дивитися наукову фантастику Я
не люблю дивитися наукову фантастику добре,
тому що я не люблю це
так, добре, будь ласка, так фільм з підігрівом
клапанів це може бути пригода
Не називайте це драмами, так що
бойовики та пригоди добре, так що тут
багато екшену, тут я
був молодим цуценятами, наче мені було 14, я
дивився, я хотів би дивитися всі фільми
про Джеймса Бонда, о, ти божевільний, тобі
точно потрібно дивитися  наш наступний урок,
тому що наш наступний урок буде
про Джеймса Бонда так, так що це
оголошення так, я сподіваюся, так, і давайте
зробимо це останній раз, коли наукова фантастика
не те, що я люблю мити наукову фантастику,
іноді це дуже цікаво, добре,
і останній для  твоя слава добре
я люблю завжди дивитися драму моя дружина
добре, звичайно, приємно мати
поруч з тобою дружину, ми плачемо разом
так,
хлопці, домашнє завдання для вашого наступного уроку,
скажімо, складіть свої фільми піраміди та
напишіть речення про  Ви можете
використовувати зображення, яке використовується, щоб ваші
улюблені фільми були добре, і приклад для
вас. Я люблю дивитися драми. Я
люблю дивитися комедії
.  потрібно припинити урок, тому
дуже дякую і побачимося наступного разу
[Музика],
де я не був так картопля рости
свята вода - о,
так, так, що можна назвати, що дасть
продовження прийти, що la nice квитки
сирої через значок клубу  Я маю на увазі, що я вставляю
тут фото синій акронім спільноти, де,
оскільки не мій найкоротший шлях, особливий
спеціальний пошук для мене зараз, особливо
співавторів революцій, підштовхнути мою лінію balerion,
це було більше не чіти уникати Непалу
Шейла уособила раптово вирости
космічний формуляр Алан серйозно
спритний у серйозному  симптоми для мене як
стабільний вихід Брежнєв або Мак Міні
оцінюють віллу, на якій Черчілль купив
трохи TMNT Lea, тепер європейський, так, але
Буш просто стріляв у мене Ямашіро їжу,
яка має суф  сьогодні вдало атакував Мачадо
або зробив трохи хірургічний крок
вперед, оскільки Аліса в поділилася ботанічними
лікарями Джимом Джеймсом Бондом. Я думаю, що це
пригода, а також його дії, а також це
те, що ця історична відома наука
функція також іноді, тому що вони
не мають реальних речей осторонь
[Музика]
ви